all right hello everyone welcome to
another episode of q a about history of
Science and Technology and I'm happy to
try and talk about any things I know
about about General History of Science
and Technology or particular things that
I've personally been involved in
ETC let's see I see a number of
questions saved up here
uh aqua asks was the 1970s truly the
Golden Age of electronics
it's an interesting question I mean the
uh
uh you know just to sort of
discuss kind of
you know electricity became electricity
in various forms like static electricity
was known in Antiquity but electricity
has something with wires and batteries
and so on that's kind of a thing of the
that really emerged in the early 1800s
and then the sort of uses of electricity
for things like making light bulbs
telephones and so on that's kind of a
late 1800s story and then the whole
understanding of kind of the
relationship well the idea of
electromagnets the idea that you can use
electricity to make magnetism that was
something that I guess became known
not sure exactly when solenoids and
things like that were invented but the
idea of electromagnetic induction the
notion that you can uh induce a current
with a magnetic field induced magnetic
field with the current and so on that
got understood with folks like Faraday
and then kind of mathematicized by folks
like Maxwell in the 1870s 1880s kind of
time frame and and then the the sort of
the expectation of things like radio
from Heinrich Hertz
um who famously people asked him what's
this going to be good for well it's just
a kind of an interesting validation of
Maxwell's equations but it was only
subsequently the people understood that
radio and the transmission of
electromagnetic radiation through free
space was an important thing in its own
right it's always interesting when there
is a phenomenon in physics for example
that gets recognized and like why is
this useful nobody knows like political
crystals were discovered I think in the
early 19 hundreds maybe long before the
use for computer displays was understood
ferrites for example what were used for
many forms of memory you know disk
drives these kinds of things before the
age of solid state disks and so on
um that ferrites were I don't know when
they were discovered but I'm I'm
guessing certainly the materials were
known for a long time I think the
phenomenon of fairy magnetism is
probably a phenomenon of the of the
early 20th century
um but certainly recognized long before
the idea of storing large amounts of
information in
um
uh in in a in in a magnetic material I
mean the the big difference is in a
Ferro magnet like iron is a ferromagnet
iron carbon Cobalt nickel are the famous
ones and then there are rare us like
gadolinium and so on which are even
stronger Ferro magnets the point there
is that that's a place where all the
atomic spins line up and you get sort of
a big magnetic field for the whole
sample fairy magnets you can have these
little domains where you have magnets in
one way and one part one another way and
another part which is really useful if
you're trying to store a bunch of data
on something like magnetic disk but any
case the um
sort of that was uh
um
uh that was kind of the the early
Evolution there then there was the
adventure of the vacuum tube I think
that was leader forest was the often
usually attributed
the the adventure of the vacuum tube and
that was kind of the idea of using
um uh using the fact that a hot wire
will uh emit a stream of electrons which
can be sort of picked up elsewhere but
if that stream of electrons and this
only works if it's in a vacuum because
otherwise the electrons get absorbed by
the air and other things but you have a
sort of hot wire and it's kind of
streaming through uh and the electrons
can be guided by magnetic field for
example or an electric field and but you
can have kind of a gate that prevents
the electrons from coming through and
that allows you to make a switch and
that led to the things like triodes
which were you know they were they were
big things several inches tall usually
um that were glass tubes that um uh were
I had vacuum inside and they glowed
because there were actual hot wires that
were emitting electrons I know when I
was a kid
um there was still plenty of devices
that had vacuum tubes vacuum tubes the
American name in British English they're
called valves
um that I'm not quite sure why they're
called valves actually maybe uh maybe
because it's like opening and closing of
valve I'm not sure but anyway this sort
of the triode was the the quintessential
version of this where you would have uh
that there would be kind of this you
know current could flow from one place
to the other with a sort of a gate that
would determine uh whether the whether
the current could flow or not and that
allowed you to make a switch and
eventually an amplifier because the the
effect of that intermediate gate
was had that you could make a small
change there and there will be a big
change in the amount of current that
passed through and that allowed you to
effectively amplify the effect of what
you were sending to the gate so that was
kind of the um uh
there's a whole technology built up of
vacuum tubes and they got very elaborate
pentodes and uh that meant you know
five-legged creatures and a whole
elaborate system and you know the
typical radio would have
a few handful two three whatever vacuum
tubes in it
um as part of its electronic
amplification mechanism
okay so that was the that was the story
until the 1940s I think if I remember
correctly was it 1947 I'm not sure
um when the transistor was invented and
that was um
uh
um the uh uh
bardeen
Shockley Britain I think
uh I certainly met Bill Budden but uh
the other two not
um the uh bardeen was was subsequently
was the person who figured out the um uh
was one of the people who figured out
the BCS theory of superconductivity so
he got his two Nobel prizes one for
transistors one for superconductivity
um and he was the professor at
University of Illinois actually uh at um
even overlapping with the time when I
was there but any case very um
dignified Old Flower by the time I knew
him
um the
so in any case the the transistor was a
a thing invented by using semiconductors
semiconductors were a type of materials
silicon and germanium are the two most
famous that had been discovered Oh Long
earlier sometime in the 1800s I think
um to be something
where kind of when you push them hard
enough they'll conduct electricity but
otherwise they won't they have this this
Gap where you need to push them with a
certain voltage for to to make them
conduct electricity so then the idea for
transistor was to kind of mess around
with that that um to dope the
semiconductor mess around with that uh
with exactly where that transmission of
electricity works to make a sandwich I
think the the first transistors were
probably npn transistors
um with different doping in the three
layers and uh I think that's right
um
and uh
that was something where you know the
very first transistors were were still I
think fairly small compared to vacuum
tubes but were kind of this you know you
could you could see them I mean I
remember I had a transistor radio when I
was a kid Circa in 1965 1966 that had
was it one or two transistors in it and
they were kind of a things with a little
little piece of you know a semiconductor
I guess very hard to see
um not not tiny you know several
millimeters across and then a big sort
of heat sink uh that was big piece of
metal that was uh
um uh sort of dumping out the heat from
the operation of this transistor but
that was
so transistors allowed for
the possibility of of um uh sort of much
more
uh the the lower voltage kind of
circuitry because vacuum tubes tend to
use uh significant voltages uh um
semiconductors tend to use you know six
volts or whatever
the um uh then
I I think the sort of the the big
innovation
in the 1960s was the idea of
microprocessors and the idea of
integrated circuits because the original
thing had been where you get a
transistor it comes an individual
transistor with this little three legs
then you would solder that into a
circuit board or something and that was
the transistor but then the idea arrives
I think at Texas Instruments that um one
could uh make a uh one could take one
slab of silicon instead of doping the
Silicon just to have these layers for an
individual transistor you could dope the
Silicon differently in different places
and you could make a whole circuit on
the piece of silicon and that led to
integrated circuits and microprocessors
and the um
the kind of uh the technology was
essentially you make this photographic
mask and then you optically just make
the features that make uh
demagnify it so to speak and then you
use ultraviolet light to uh have some
acid which either it will cause you to
etch the Silicon or not whatever
um the whole elaborate these days very
elaborate and very expensive process to
make uh microplusters but kind of there
were there were a bunch of different
technical things that had to exist for
that to work like you had to be able to
make uh silicon crystals that were very
pure and didn't have a lot of defects in
them you had to be able to control all
of these processes really well but the
first microprocessors started to exist
in the in the um late 1960s I guess
um and uh
you know I think the
they kind of were too late for the space
program and and things of that type
um and uh the um
I think uh the first place where most
people got to see those things was in
calculators which kind of burst onto the
scene around 1971 1972
um where you would have these four
function calculators that were based on
microprocessors
um and that ran off batteries and so on
and that was kind of a a big place where
where many people got to see kind of
microprocessors in action
then
well
in the
in the decade that followed sort of
microprocessors showed up everywhere and
uh in computers I I think in lots of
other kinds of devices uh it I think the
um
the kind of the the early idea was there
were particular families of micro
processors and other sort of smaller
scale things that are more like um
micro can what would nowadays be called
microcontrollers Arduino style things
that showed up and some of those
Technologies haven't actually changed
much in a long time
um but then you know started to show up
all over the place and uh then gradually
the the progressive technology of making
that processors got better and better
and kind of Moore's Law kicked in of you
know every 18 months double the
capabilities
um and that was a sort of huge
engineering achievement over the course
of many decades and leading to all sorts
of uh leading to the semiconductor
industry as it is today I think in
the you know they're different parts of
the story I mean there's the story of
microprocessors and how they Advanced
and the various times when people said
we can do better you know silicon
microprocessors you know we can use
germanium instead we can use gallium
arsenide instead uh none of those
Technologies really panned out big time
they all had the the kind of force of
economy of scale to do with silicon and
CMOS and and semiconductor you know
metal oxide semiconductor technology and
so on the force of of the economies of
scale in that area seem to exceed any
potential advantages for these other
Technologies although I think some
gallium arsenide stuff is used for uh
very fast uh kinds of maybe optically
collect connected microprocessor
technology and so on but there were
there were multiple attempts to use
other Technologies other than
semiconductors to do electronics over
the course course of years and in a
sense one could see the modern
enthusiasm for Quantum Computing to be
another iteration of that idea even some
of the same Technologies like
superconducting judges and Junctions and
so on are reappearing as they were
things that had been discussed in the
context of traditional microprocessors
back in the 1980s and so on and hadn't
really made it there and are now kind of
being well it's another thing where we
could potentially feed different physics
into making a computational system now
another branch of the whole world of
these things is analog Electronics
Digital Electronics where you have sort
of data going around in discrete ones
and zeros and so on that's how
essentially all computers work but
multiple times in in people have been
enthusiastic about various kinds of
analog approaches and there's still
analog circuitry and many kinds of
devices because in the end you've got
some kind of electric motor that's where
you know it runs faster if you put
higher current through it things like
this
increasingly things that you might have
thought were kind of analog circuitry
like the antenna aspects of radios and
things increasingly that's as efficient
to do digitally with software radio and
things of that kind but uh and and sort
of the the experience has been that
analog Computing hasn't really been very
successful I mean I remember I used
analog computer for a bit Los Alamos
National Lab back in the when was it uh
must have been 1982-ish time frame and
it was uh kind of you know the idea
there is instead of doing everything in
terms of bits and ones and zeros you
just have and the voltage is 5.734 or
something and you're running that thing
through an electric circuit that is a
traditional circuit with inductors and
capacitors and so on and you're kind of
taking for example a differential
equation
and you're saying I've got this
differential equation I want to solve I
can convert that differential equation
into something that corresponds to the
differential equation for this electric
circuit as an analog thing as an analog
circuit so to speak and then I can just
see what the electric circuit does and
that will tell me things about the
solution to my differential equation
that technology really never panned out
in in a serious way it was very hard to
be reproducible it was you know oh it
mattered whether the thing was hot or
cold and things like this and it just
didn't seem very convenient it wasn't
the same kind of thing where you could
say oh I've got this piece of software
let me give it to you on a floppy disk
or whatever the the programming of an
analog computer involved actual wires
going from here to there I think the one
that Los Alamos had some whole elaborate
scheme for for doing something which was
a little bit repeatable but it seemed
more like an old-fashioned telephone
switching system where the physical wire
has to go from here to there rather than
a modern kind of virtual circuit digital
switching system
so a few a few thoughts about that
history I think that um the
the the advance of kind of design for
microprocessors and for analog circuitry
those have gone into rather different
tracks I mean microprocessor design a
lot of that early on people thought
about optimization of logic circuits oh
we've got this particular logic
expression that it represents a piece of
an adding uh an Adder for example let's
find the minimum set of gates the
minimum set of transistors that we can
use to compute that particular function
that's one sort of Direction the other
Direction by now when there are billions
of transistors there are just all kinds
of different
issues about how you manage that design
and there are different levels of layers
of design whether it's the kind of
physical layer where you're worrying
about all these two wires too close to
each other or The Logical layer what
you're worrying about is there a bug in
this algorithm that we're burning into
our chip and so on and uh there a lot of
sort of development of
um
of kind of the methodology for Designing
microprocessors and large
large systems uh there was at various
times there had been various degrees of
enthusiasm for the role of your own chip
kind of approach silicon compilers was a
a thing in the 1970s particularly uh
that people were enthusiastic about then
they're a field programmable gated rays
fpgas which are kind of a an organized
structure of circuit that you can pick
or I want these particular gates from
this circuit to be used and that's a way
to kind of make in Hardware something
which is not not an absolutely arbitrary
optimized circuit but it's something
where you can put your particular kind
of um system
and you can make it something which is
implemented in hardware and again it you
know people have thought oh it's going
to be so easy to make chips that
everybody who has an algorithm is just
going to make a trip for the algorithm
that really didn't pan out again the
sort of economies of scale to do with
building general purpose microprocessors
and the ease with which you could Define
that new software really vastly exceeded
the advantages that you got by sort of
the roll your own chip kind of approach
an intermediate stage is microcode which
was a thing which one heard about more
in past years than today which is kind
of like well you've got this raw
microprocessor and it has all these
Gates and things in it and places where
data goes from here to there and there's
a lot of detailed information about
timing of things and what people would
do is and I'm sure it's still done in in
a computer or microprocessor you would
say well I've got this instruction which
is actually going to be implemented in
microcode it's going to be implement
answered by having all these different
gates open and close and signals sent
from here to there at a very detailed
Hardware level but at the level it's
going to be exposed to software it's
just some particular instruction and and
so that's that's another kind of
intermediate approach but I think in
terms of analog Electronics sort of the
design methodology for analog
Electronics has been very different from
the design methodology for digital
electronics where it's all about logic
minimization and things like this in
analog Electronics it really is kind of
you've got these equations you've got to
solve them and uh it's not the same type
of mathematics and so on it's really
calculus continuous mathematics that's
involved and people try from time to
time things like using genetic
algorithms to say let me invent a
circuit for this I think there's been
some success in that of you know this
this thing I'm trying to achieve that
has these particular characteristics can
I invent a circuit that does that that's
going to have wires and capacitors and
it's going to have an inductor with some
particular you know inductance and so on
and can I make that thing and I think
there's been slow progress in that kind
of area where sort of early AI
approaches have been fairly useful but
my impression is that that's if you were
to compare sort of the the level of
sophistication of design for digital
electronics to analog Electronics
digital is is far out ahead in that
regard and that's probably yet another
reason why digital in addition to the
you know the programmability the fact
that the sort of software that you can
exchange and so on is why that that has
a great Advantage there
uh let's see we have all kinds of other
questions here okay Taz asks what's the
history of hacking when did security
risks become a prominent issue well I
know a few things about that
you know I remember when I was a kid
probably must have been
1970-ish time frame I remember hearing
this rumor about how people and I think
it was MIT
had discovered that if you were to type
too many characters into a password
field that some of the data from that
the the code would assume that the
Oregon type some number of characters
it's a buffer overflow exploit so to
speak where uh sort of some of that
extra stuff would get into the innards
of the operating system and cause all
sorts of bad things to happen and I
remember hearing that it's probably the
first time I heard about any kind of
exploit that was when I was like 10
years old or something
um and uh I think the
um I I should explain that the term
hacking was a term or hackers was a term
that actually originated in the 60s I
think at MIT
um and uh a bunch of people who I've
known actually were involved in that and
it really just meant doing cool
surprising hacks with computers it
didn't mean breaking into computers it
just meant doing clever things with
computers that nobody expected and that
led to for example a famous document
called hack mem
that I think came out in 1970 that um I
think my friend Paul gospel was involved
in that and several other people uh Rich
Chappelle maybe
um doesn't go below maybe who I don't
know Michael bieler perhaps
um the uh
and that was this thing that's a list of
I don't know 400 kind of cool things you
can do with computers that's like oh
this particular set of machine
instructions for a PDP 10 will draw a
totally weird fractal curve except they
didn't call it fractals yet then but um
so that was kind of an early meaning to
the term hacker
um was an hacks was these you know cool
things you could do with computers
I think then
the uh uh sort of in public awareness
the the really
dramatic
kind of moment when people became aware
of of sort of computer security in a big
way was the the Morris worm
um Robert Morris who's whose dad was a
computer security researcher at uh ATT
at Bell labs and I think I met the the
young Morris at some party when I was a
consultant at Bell labs when he was a
high school kid but um uh he
subsequently wound up as a student at
Cornell and um uh decided to build a
computer worm that um uh somehow got out
and this must have been
1988 89
um sort of got out and infected lots of
computers around the world
um and started just replicating itself
in the nothing could be alive nothing
can you know if you're if you
self-replicate you must be alive or this
was an example of something that was
only alive in the computer so to speak
but it um it you know it replicated
itself and the main thing it did that
was bad was that it just kept on
grinding the CPUs of computers uh sort
of trying to replicate itself and trying
to transmit copies of itself and that
meant the computers kind of ground to
Halt just running the worm rather than
doing what they were supposed to do now
I suppose I must have known more about
computer security by that time because
one of the things we did as a company
was we had a connection to the internet
back from 1986 when company was started
and um uh I had arranged to make our
Gateway computer be a very obscure
workstation computer made by a Sony that
was whose operating system was based on
Japanese and was just a very obscure
computer that didn't make it
commercially but I I guess I knew enough
to decide that our gateway to the
internet should be that very obscure
computer
um and that turned out to be a huge win
because the Morris worm was compiled for
a bunch of different standard kinds of
computers but nobody would compile it
for this incredibly obscure uh Japanese
computer and so for example our
computers at our company didn't get
infected by that worm so I wonder how I
knew to do that it's a good question
um I certainly had been I mean another
sort of whole branch of computer
security was cryptography and that was
something that I for example knew a
decent amount about by that time
um and I mean just to give a little bit
of the sketch of the history of
cryptography uh you know even back in
Antiquity you know it is said and
probably it's true that Julius Caesar
used a Caesar Cipher which essentially
takes every message and the letters of
the alphabet just get shifted did you
know four or five up or whatever it is
and the key is how many letters are you
Shifting the letters the Alphabet by
um and uh at a time when you know it's
sort of an interesting question whether
people would really not understand what
that message meant because they just
didn't have sort of the abstract
thinking associated with well let's
shift the letters down but that was one
um uh one early approach was just shift
the letters in a message you give then
there were vignes ciphers that came in I
don't know 1400s 1500s things like that
they were things where the the amount
you shifted the letter would sort of
gradually ratchet up as you went through
the message and then that led to all
sorts of encryption devices that
involved uh Cipher wheels and so on by
the way there was a whole other branch
of using Code books where you would say
you know if you say 10 4 it means
whatever
um the uh where you would just have a a
a a a book of code words
another approach was the so-called
one-time pad approach where you would
take some particular uh well either a a
um
uh a sort of a a secret book or even
something we just said starting at this
letter in this newspaper on this day
we're just going to take those letters
and use those to determine the key so if
the letter was if that next letter was a
c for example then move the characters
three letters forward if it was a d move
them four letters forward or whatever
else it was so that was that was another
kind of approach to these things I mean
there was one thing I don't know if it
still goes on I I it certainly did
during the Cold War was this very
strange radio stations number stations I
guess they were called where you'd you'd
tune your radio to that frequency and it
would just be somebody reading off a
series of numbers and
um uh I guess those were used for some
kind of one-time pad cryptography
um as as part of the kind of whole uh
Cold War Espionage uh picture but just a
very strange thing to find as you kind
of turn your your radio dial through
through different frequencies
um
anyway the in in the in cryptography the
um by the 1930s there were these pretty
elaborate machines that were being made
um that uh became famous in World War II
as a in the Enigma machines I think they
had originated in countries like Sweden
and so on
um but there were there been a tradition
of building these things and they were
kind of uh you know a series of wheels
that would and um and then sort of uh
which made electrical connections and
then some whole uh sort of way of of
scrambling those and then the result was
you know you press one button on an
Enigma machine and wheels turn and
somewhere it displays what the next
letter that you should put in the
ciphertext is so that was kind of the
state of the art in in World War II and
there were slightly more elaborate
versions than the Enigma machines that
existed then famously those were broken
by uh the British Bletchley Park using
these early electromechanical computers
that would essentially just search
through for different possible keys that
might be used and the question was given
that you choose a particular key is the
is the message that you get out a
plausible message or is it gibberish is
it German or is it gibberish and that
led people like Alan Turing to kind of
think a lot about the statistics of
messages and I kind of suspect that uh
Turing had pretty much figured out the
sort of information Theory idea that was
later really developed by Claude Shannon
um touring and Shannon had certainly met
um and uh at the end of at the end of
the war Shannon published all that stuff
about kind of the redundancy of messages
you know how much do you how much can
you tell if you've seen a queue it must
be followed by you there's there's it's
a very redundant thing to put to you
there but in general in in languages
there's a certain amount of redundancy
in English it's maybe 50 or something
and that's the thing you use when you're
doing crypto analysis because you need
to know is the thing that you are
producing a plausible piece of text or
is it something that is sort of
implausible and you get to figure out
plausibility from using the redundancy
so in any case that was kind of the the
state of the art in um uh in World War
II for for cryptography
um
what emerged shortly after the war
um uh shift registers which were kind of
a thing of electronics where you have um
kind of a a series of of vacuum tubes or
something and you're constantly shifting
the value always to the left and then
you feed it back the one all the way to
the left shifts or shift to the right
and that's something you can use as a
way of storing information because if it
takes a while to shift down and it keeps
on you know going around again you can
use that to just store the bits
um and uh but but then
the idea was stopped in the in the 1940s
I think late 1940s of having uh feedback
shift registers where you have not just
circulating everything around but
tapping into the into particular places
in the shift register taking the results
and for example combining them together
and using that to be the thing that you
feed back
and then so by uh the 1950s it was not
mid 1950s it was known that you could
get very long sequences of seemingly
random numbers and soul galam who I knew
was the person who really figured out
how to mathematicize that question and
turn it into a question about
polynomials over finite Fields it became
sort of the big application area for
polynomials over finite Fields
polynomials where the variables can just
be zero one mod two things like this and
uh one thing that happened was that you
could figure out these particular you
could represent the Taps on the shift
register by polynomials by just sort of
saying the the tap is at position 11 or
something so you have an x to the 11 and
it's also position seven so you have an
x to the seven and so on and from the
characteristics of those polynomials you
could work out the uh the the the cycle
how many how many different
configurations the shift register could
take on before it cycled back to the the
original on and so then there were these
maximal length feedback shift register
sequences that got developed by by
solgalom
um and those have I mean interestingly
those are probably the single most used
algorithm in history is the idea of a
maximal length linear feedback shift
register those are used you know GPS
satellites use them that's what they're
transmitting uh cellular ellipso left
only uses it for code development
multiplexing
um the uh
um the thing that um
uh it's even used a lot in for example
transmitting data from to computer
displays and so on partly because it's
very easy to decode a linear feedback
shift register sequence it has a nice
feature that it's always sort of having
ones and zeros sort of flapping around
and you never have something where
there's zero voltage on the wire and
it's often very convenient Electronics
to never have zero voltage or to not
have zero voltage for very long so it's
better to send this thing encoded in
this form where it's easier to decode
but it's always uh it's always kind of
not not just making a zero so in any
case feedback shift registers were a
thing
um I'm not sure to what extent they were
used for cryptography I kind of suspect
that particularly in the Soviet Union
there were long linear feedback shift
registers that were used for
cryptographic systems
um in the in the 1940s and 50s and so on
and perhaps perhaps beyond that time and
then in the U.S the sort of the next big
step in cryptography was the data
encryption standard Des which arrived
around 1970-ish and that was the thing
that was kind of an electronic version
of something a little bit like an Enigma
machine but not quite the same setup it
had these so you would have these blocks
of of data zeros and ones and you would
have substitutions where you take one
block and replace it with another block
and you would permute blocks around and
so on and so that was the the sort of
the one of the key parts of that
technology with the so-called s-boxes
the substitution boxes which would say
whenever you have this sequence of ones
and zeros replace it by that sequence of
ones and zeros one of the things that
was very mysterious was why were the S
boxes chosen the way they were because
they just seemed like random kind of uh
updates of of collections of ones and
zeros by other collections of ones and
zeros I I eventually found out that uh
in the late 1950s in in the U.S National
Security Agency for example had had a
whole bunch of mathematicians involved
with this investigating uh these kinds
of these kinds of sort of
one-dimensional systems where you would
have a series of bits and you would take
blocks of bits and replace them with
other blocks of bits well that turns out
to be my favorite computational system a
one-dimensional cellular automaton
essentially and so they had investigated
um and even tabulated lots of kinds of
properties of one-dimensional cellular
automata looking for ones that had
certain kinds of reversibility
properties and some of the ones they
found I think turned into the S boxes of
Des
um because they were they were things
that had sort of been identified as
interesting in connection with linear
feedback shift registers and cellular
automata so in any case that was uh for
a long time the kind of the market was
sort of flooded with uh uh kind of
government subsidized uh encryption
equipment that was
um uh that that based on des and that
was sort of the standard for commercial
encryption there were then companies
that popped up I think particularly in
Switzerland and Israel were the two sort
of leading places where companies would
pop up with various kinds of encryption
techniques that they said our encryption
is better than other people's encryption
and look you know it comes from this
fine fine has this fine lineage that was
a time when kind of a lot of the my
encryption is secure came from saying
and you don't know how my encryption
Works inside and it had been a big deal
that I think it had been focused in
Poland who managed to get hold of a
German Enigma machine in World War II
and uh that had been kind of a key part
of being able to decode Enigma machines
was knowing how they worked inside and
the the uh kind of um
the thing that um uh was um
um
the uh
that was sort of some of the tradition
in the 1970s and 80s even about
encryption had to do with well you don't
know how it works inside I think there
have been a time uh this is a uh sorry I
think from the Korean War there was a
U.S ship what was it called USS Pueblo I
think
um that was captured in the Korean War
and it had a bunch of encryption
equipment and it was you know big metal
thing that was its encryption system and
uh
they really didn't want it to be
captured and so somebody you know Took
an Ax to it and tried to destroy it but
it wasn't successfully destroyed and I
think that was one of the things that
was sort of a big impetus for U.S
military for example to get more
involved with sort of uh small
electronics that among other things you
know if you the next generation of
encryption equipment if somebody was
about to capture your ship you could
just destroy the encryption equipment
and
people wouldn't the other the enemy
wouldn't be able to get hold of it but
any case in the uh by the 1970s and
1980s
um the kind of the the there were these
commercial encryption outfits there was
a lot of kind of uh IBM was very
involved in Des the data encryption
standard
um and that was sort of typical
commercial encryption was done with Des
um
and people uh then onto the scene came
public key cryptography the RSA uh
algorithm I think that was 1984 or so
maybe 1983.
um I myself actually invented a sort of
crypto system based on the rule 37
automaton at that time it was sort of a
big issue because there were sort of all
sorts of questions about well if you
find a a good strong encryption
technique should you tell the world
about it
um you know is that okay to do that or
do is that something that you know only
governments should be able to do and I
think the thing that emerged was partly
through the the RSA
um
crypto system you know by the time there
was an article in Scientific American
which had a circulation of you know two
and a half million or something about in
those days about this thing it was kind
of out and uh the um and so the kind of
things flipped to the point where the
idea that nobody knew how your
encryption system worked wasn't the
source of security it was that the
actual that even if you knew how the
thing worked it was still sort of
mathematically secure and that was kind
of uh that that was a sort of a key
change
and and by the way a lot of the systems
that are used in I mean something like
RSA cryptography is good for things like
key exchange where you have small amount
of data that you have to deal with
cryptographically but when you have a
gobs and gobs of data you end up using
one of these stream ciphers or one of
these other kinds of non-public Key
Systems like the rule 30 system or like
derivatives of Des
um which like the you know Shaw sha uh
systems for for hashing and so on are
related to those whole s-box
um
Etc uh
uh kinds of methods but anyway so
encryption was a thing which by the I
would say by the late 80s was a thing
people sort of knew about and it was a
thing one routinely did I have to say uh
you know the Unix operating system for
example developed in the in the uh mid
70s
um was it had a function called Crypt
that was based on essentially the Enigma
machine or maybe the I think maybe the
purple
um Cipher
um and um it was uh you know you could
go see its code and it was it was just
doing that kind of encryption a kind of
a story to tell against myself is that
um uh when I worked on developing the
system called SMP which was kind of a
forerunner of mathematical modern
language back in 1979 to 1981 kind of
time frame one of my sort of clever
ideas was let's encrypt the source code
so that it won't kind of go walking away
so we did that using
um and I said but let's modify the Unix
script program because if somebody is
going to break encryption they're going
to break the generic Unix script program
so let's modify it to have our own
version that is less likely to be broken
quickly so okay that story of course the
next step is and we lost the password so
decades later there I am trying to you
know talk to everybody who'd worked on
it saying do you remember the password
well nobody remember the password it
then turned out actually about what was
it eight years ago so young fellow
um
oh actually now works at the company
um was uh
managed to break the encryption without
ever finding out the password by just
using kind of statistical features of
things managed to reconstruct the source
uh without without ever determining what
the password had been fed into the
modified clip program somewhat
frustratingly we had the uh the
encrypted code of the modified Crooks
program so it was kind of a bootstrap
can you find this from that and so on
and uh and we didn't know that but
anyway that was that was sort of a that
was fairly I would say you know
cryptography was a known thing I will
tell another story about cryptography
from those days
um the Ed editor which was a lion editor
that came with Unix had in a piece of
very terrible user experience if you
type the single letter X when you were
in a mode when the editor was kind of
listening for editor commands rather
than taking sort of text for your for
your file when you typed I think the
single letter X it would encrypt your
file and the next things you typed would
be masked and they will be used as the
password
okay so I was actually I was visiting
Harvard I think
um and uh using a computer there this
must have been 1982 or some some such
other around that time 81 maybe probably
82.
um and uh there I am writing some
program about cosmology and trying to
compute some interesting thing I thought
um at least at the time about cosmic
strings
um and uh uh at some key moment
I kind of thought I was typing into the
file but actually I was typing to the
editor so to speak and I typed an X and
then I typed random other letters I
don't know what are the letters I typed
and my file got encrypted and that was
kind of a disaster for that project
because there I had you know the code
I've been writing was encrypted there
was nothing I could do about it I
subsequently uh when I was a consultant
at my labs I I ran into the person who'd
written that aspect to the uh Ed editor
and made a vociferous um uh you know
user experience complaint about how
ridiculous it was that a single
character typed could wind up with an
encrypted file and so on but it was part
of kind of the minimal ethic of of
um of Unix design that something like
that was possible and it's also very
much in in sort of the Unix design
methodology of just trust the user and
give them lots of power which I think
was an interesting approach but it did
have some bad side effects like that
okay so in any case the the um uh more
on the history of computer security I
think the Morris worm was really the
thing that woke people up to sort of the
possibility of uh uh of computer
security issues kind of um uh on on the
internet so to speak
um
you know many things have happened since
many strange creatures have been
released uh sort of on purpose by
mistake things uh there's a whole
Strange World of computer security and
from what I gather it's becoming more
and more difficult to make kind of
generic computer security exploits so a
typical thing that's done in modern
times is you know there's an operating
system and somebody finds a bug in their
operating system and that bug allows you
to you know type the right incantation
or do the right thing at the right time
that allows you to kind of take control
over the operating system take control
of the computer and go and do things
with it and I would say that at the
theoretical level what's happening is
kind of interesting which is that as
soon as you can somehow get the computer
to act as a universe so the program that
you're interacting with to act as a
universal computer you can get it to do
anything so for example I'm remember an
early Hack That Somebody I knew did was
a printer the printer had sort of
connections from this was a uh some kind
of government facility where there was a
uh the printer had access from the
non-secure part and from the secure part
and it was one printer accessible from
both sides and what was done was
something where somehow you took control
of the printer and even though it was
just a printer you could kind of get it
to be computationally sophisticated
enough that it could essentially run any
program and then it could kind of crawl
its way back onto the secure side and do
bad things and I think that the um uh
the thing that um uh is kind of relevant
from a science point of view is kind of
this principle of computational
equivalence that I talk about a lot that
talks about how it's not very difficult
to get a computational system to be
capable of universal computation that
ends up being an important idea for
computer security because it's kind of
the thing that allows you even though
you think you have just a router or you
think you have just a firewall or you
think you have just a printer really
it's possible to sort of piece together
the computational elements from that to
do arbitrary computations which allows
you to do mischievous computations that
were not intended so to speak it's kind
of a a long arm of girdle sterile and
undecidability that you're kind of being
bitten with when you're kind of getting
computer systems to do things they
weren't intended to do and that's sort
of inevitable as soon as you give a
certain amount of power to these
computer systems but what I'm told is
that increasingly in developing
operating systems and things like that
you um the tools that exist for
validating things like buffer overflow
for example is really pretty you know
you you have to not be paying attention
to let your program be able to do buffer
overflow because they're pretty good
validation tools and essentially
improving methods that allow you to show
that that won't happen I mean it's still
the case that a typical sort of way in
to find a hack to find security
vulnerabilities techniques like fuzzing
where you say I've got this input that
I'm supposed to give but let me just
randomly change that input and see what
happens and see whether suddenly some
crazy thing happens
um now also in sort of the whole world
of security in in things like
smartphones it's typical to just have
these these just different sections of
capabilities that are kind of
sequestered off from each other with
only limited ways that they can
communicate and that that helps make it
really difficult to kind of break
through and and get to the wrong place
so to speak but I think in um uh and
forget now what the original question
was here oh yeah
um
I mean the whole story of um sort of
vulnerability of computers
uh with respect to computer security I
think was the thing that really came
into prominence late late 80s early 90s
um you know people have been concerned
about cryptography from probably that we
came into public awareness in the in the
probably early 1980s
um and I think in terms of the more
social engineering aspects of computer
security certainly they've been known to
people in the biz for a very very long
time but in terms of the general public
um I don't know when that really became
a thing I mean I certainly
oh gosh I mean as physical letters one
started getting I started getting
Nigerian scams and they
in what the late 1980s I think
um and that was probably you know some
of that kind of social engineering stuff
I'm sure that it happened earlier than
that maybe I just wasn't on the right
mailing list so to speak to get those
things
um but uh uh the um
the thing that um
um was I think those things are now now
have names that aren't specific to
Nigeria and I I don't even know the
things that one got back in those days
actually came from Nigeria or whether
that was part of the scam but they
tended to have the name you know they
tended to have Nigeria in their name
like french fries or something uh at
least back in back in those days
um
well let's see
I think um
uh
yeah no I mean the the whole question of
um uh of things like fishing with a pH
and uh you know all these kinds of uh
social engineering hacks are
um uh
um
you know they have come to Great much
more prominence in recent times and it's
always interesting like for a company
like ours you know we we do testing
about computer security systems and
typically the technical side of it is
fine and the human side of it is where
things go wrong of people you know
clicking on the link they shouldn't
click on and so on and we we have
instituted for a while now a fish of the
Month Club of uh kind of uh highlighting
sort of the most interesting phishing
attempts that that people report to our
computer security team uh just as a way
to raise awareness of what's out there I
don't know maybe I could tell you some
stories about um let me think
yeah I think these are harmless
uh I mean there are computer security
exploits that we've been exposed to as a
company
um and uh uh gosh they get they got
quite wild and um uh in some cases they
um
uh I would say one we Trace to Romania
and one we're pretty sure came from
North Korea
um those uh and one
longer ago came from a young kid in the
US
um and uh all of these have had all
sorts of elaborate
uh interaction with various kinds of law
enforcement
um and uh I would say that the um
uh it is interesting to see the levels
of effort that have been gone to a
different times in different ways I
would say that the um uh well the very
early one I'm remembering was from the
early 1990s and um that was uh a um
um
that was a case where
this um this must have been
when was this this was
might be just off to the web started to
exist yeah I think so
um because I remember
that well it was as a whole elaborate
story uh which maybe I shouldn't tell
but um maybe another time uh after I've
thought through whether whether the
story is is all tellable
um but uh it um I mean it you know it
features the FBI and all kinds of folks
and all kinds of strange events and um
uh all sorts of things like that and
another stories feature
um
well various kinds of
um uh human hacking which was defeated
in various ways I suppose one of I'll
say one one thing I I you know the one
that ended up getting traced to Romania
was um I think I was responsible for
that piece of tracing which was kind of
the key thing was just you take apart
the packets and you see that they have
text in them and what language is the
text turn well these days would be easy
to tell but those it wasn't quite as
easy to tell and gosh it's in Romanian
okay that's a big clue
um and that kind of uh un unraveled that
I mean there are other times in terms of
computer security attacks the things
like denial service attacks where just
people are throwing gazillions of
packets at your computers and um uh it's
not so much of a thing these days
because there are all kinds of
remediation techniques but back in early
years that was a thing and I remember
one time that happened to us and we're
like why is somebody targeting us it's
not that interesting and then we
realized we are our IP address was uh
one digit off from the IPA address of an
Internet casino and that was the thing
that was being attacked for ransom
purposes and we were just uh you know a
typo away so to speak
in any case many um uh
many things to say about that
um
Philip Australia you get to Know cover
me at Caltech not as well as I would
like certainly met him but not not as
well as I would like
um
let's see maybe one more thing here and
then I think I need to go
um
gosh
all right there's a question here from
Giovanni about what progress did
anti-gravity research
uh how far did it get in 1950s and 1960s
why did the research stop
well
I don't know in in full detail
I will say
that
the
sort of the the original theory of
gravity due to Isaac Newton in 1687
Newton's universal law of gravitation
says you know
bodies with with masses attract each
other according to gravity with an
inverse Square law and that was kind of
the theory of gravity
for for a really long time then in 1915
Einstein came along with his general
relativity which was kind of a a new
relativistic theory of gravity a new
theory of gravity that included the
effects of of special relativity and the
the idea of space time and general
relativity was kind of an interesting
Theory people worked on it
mathematically but it didn't get a lot
of traction until really the 1960s and
there was it is a mathematically very
difficult Theory to work with people
didn't understand you know were there
really black holes did what did that
mean that wasn't really understood until
the 1960s was it a coordinated
Singularity that was just kind of a
glitch in the mathematics was it a real
physical thing that you could see that
didn't really get understood until the
1960s so by the 1960s kind of the theory
of gravity Einstein's theory of gravity
from general relativity was becoming an
established thing and they were starting
to be all sorts of experimental tests of
it and there were sort of competing
theories which added extra sort of uh
detail like there was a thing called the
Brand's Dickie Theory which was a theory
that involved in addition to ordinary
gravity it would involve this scalar
field the graviton is a is a tensor
field
um and uh the um
and then that was largely excluded and
so on so any case the sort of that kind
of uh the the theory of gravity got
didn't get established that well until
the 60s and so on and still people were
still picking away at it for quite a
while I personally think that there are
still challenges to it and my guess is
that in our models of physics things
will work out a bit differently and that
might allow one to understand things
like dark matter and so on it's worth
commenting that in the late 1970s I was
involved in this uh the kind of what
became the inflation theory of the early
Universe
involves sort of things with negative
Mass effectively that's what dark energy
in the kind of modern view of cosmology
there is sort of a need to apparently to
meet the experimental results to have
the idea that there is somehow in the
universe something with negative mass
that is causing things to be pushed
apart rather than attracted together
that's a thing that's sort of very
exotic and nobody knows what dark energy
is maybe it doesn't even exist and so on
that's also a thing that sort of emerges
in the inflationary theory of the early
universe and so on it's kind of a a
funky thing that theories of physics
particularly Ones based on well early on
on spontaneous symmetry baking on this
kind of hack that lets you kind of
account for the masses of particles by
introducing this field that suffuses the
Universe and that sort of gives Mass to
particles but that whole sort of tower
of physics has implications about sort
of negative Mass things that might exist
but those were not the motivations for
anti-gravity research in the 50s and and
so on that is a a modern reason why
anti-gravity wouldn't isn't necessarily
you know if if you take the Orthodox
view of physics today it involves dark
energy which has anti-gravity so we
don't happen to be able to get bottle of
dark energy we don't know anything
really about what it is but that it
isn't the case that oh physics proves
that there can't be anti-gravity not
true the the um all the all the examples
we know and have experience of of
positive Mass things which have positive
gravity not anti-gravity but in terms of
sort of research and anti-gravity I
think
well there was a
kind of the UFO
time now these things have the new name
of uaps but the time when people were
there are strange things in the sky
um that was probably had its peak I
think in the 1950s and maybe 1960s and
possibly because there were strange
things in the sky being tested you know
various kinds of military things various
kinds of uh
um strange balloons and things like this
there perhaps were strange things in the
sky and uh you know there and and it was
something a time when I guess another
thing that was true at that time was it
was a time when the government in the US
for example was the place that did more
research that was the place that had the
most advanced science and technology and
the government was keeping some of those
you know kept things secret and so there
was kind of this this vibe that if
something was being discovered it might
be being discovered by the government
and the goal government might be keeping
it secret
as opposed to more modern times where
the commercial sector has tended to be
the thing that is most out in front in
terms of most kinds of of research and
development and that's a place where you
know often the most the Pinnacle of
achievement shows up in a piece of
consumer electronics and it isn't it's a
different vibe from the 1950s and 1960s
where it was like the government behind
closed doors is discovering the the most
the most dramatic things I think that
probably made for uh a time when when
people felt that way it was also the
case that I think quite responsibly the
US government for example in the 50s and
and so on wanted to investigate
everything that might be conceivable
because it was like well maybe the
Soviets will be doing this you know
maybe they're using telepathy to control
you know their drones or something maybe
they're using anti-gravity to do this
maybe their user thing maybe they've
discovered how to you know wire up the
brains of porpoises to be able to uh you
know be do this or that or you know all
kinds of strange things that seem to us
now like oh that didn't work we know
that isn't possible but one didn't know
it wasn't possible and if one is kind of
trying to make sure that one's military
prowess you know is the best so to speak
it makes perfect sense to investigate
all those things it it probably you know
you can ask what percentage of your uh
budget should be spent investigating
sort of Wilder things
um and I don't know the answer to that
but it's not zero
um because you know if it ends up being
zero and we've seen that in some
commercial cases with large companies of
of oops we forgot to investigate AI type
thing and that turns out to be sort of a
bad idea
um and um I think
it's um so you know the fact that these
kinds of things were being investigated
at that time is sort of not surprising I
don't really know what was done to make
anti-gravity I mean I think that um
people
gosh I'm trying to remember I mean there
were
there were various kinds of Perpetual
Motion machines I remember that were
sort of mostly electrical and magnetic
in nature
um I don't know yeah I don't I don't
know what was actually done to make the
anti-gravity machine and I don't know
whether it was kind of uh uh an
electrical play or a or a thing spinning
around and and whatever I mean I think
one of the things that gets tricky in
knowing sort of uh you know I'm trying
to remember there was one of these
things oh boy somebody showed me at some
point and one of the things that's
tricky is with things like gyroscopes or
in general with um you can end up with
something where sort of you pick it up
and it does something you don't expect
it to do because it's got the saying in
momentum and it's kind of pulling itself
in some weird Direction and that can
sort of make things I'm trying to
remember now that there was a particular
example oh boy oh gosh
forgetting sometime this must have been
beginning of the 1980s or something uh
some sort of claim of a of a it weighs
less than than it should weigh you put
things in and you put more in and the
thing weighs less when you put more in
so to speak which is something that
shouldn't be the case the the force of
gravity should increase when you put
more stuff in there
um and uh obviously you can have things
you know if it's if it's floating on the
air like a you know like a lighter than
air less dense than air you know helium
balloon or something that's a different
story but this was a thing where in a
vacuum you sort of put more in and it
weighed less I don't remember what that
what that story was but that was uh you
know that was a a time when those things
well that was a bit late for those
things seem implausible
um but uh uh yeah no I I think what
really killed a lot of that stuff
was some when was this this must have
been the 70s maybe the 80s a certain
senator proxmeyer who started giving out
these so-called Golden Fleece awards for
sort of crazy apparently wasteful uh
r d efforts carried out by the by parts
of the US government or contractors for
the US government and I think one of the
famous consequences of that was there
had been a seti search for
extraterrestrial intelligence effort
that had been kind of a NASA type effort
and um that won one of these Golden
Fleece Awards and that was you know oh
where are we spending money searching
for Little Green Men type thing
um and uh that kind of killed Government
funding for seti for a long time and it
sort of came back a bit in the form of
astrobiology which is kind of the the
modern polite version with slightly
different objectives and slightly
different methods
um and most of the sort of funding and
interest in study uh at least in the US
went into kind of private philanthropic
charitable kinds of uh entities and not
all that much was done I I actually
myself was not that impressed with what
was done and uh I think it's a I think
it's one of these things it was a
philosophically doomed problem that it's
not a question of of uh uh you know it's
there's sort of a question of what it
even means to have intelligence and then
what it means to have communication and
so on and that's um uh you know that's
the um
that's the thing to to to to to think
about that you know I think I Giovanni
commenting on on crazy how much we still
don't know yeah I mean I think one of
the things to realize is that a lot of
these things that have come up as oh it
might be possible to have anti-gravity
oh it might be possible to have time
travel oh it might be possible to have
telepathy or it might be possible Etc et
cetera et cetera
you know
in many cases the story is more
complicated than you think you know the
the most obvious thing turns out not to
be true the most obvious thing oh you
put this kind of paint on the bottom of
your spacecraft and the thing will
suddenly not feel the force of gravity
that's probably not a thing but it's uh
that that you know to prove that it's
impossible
is basically impossible in fact even if
we know and we think we do know its
framework at least the fundamental
Theory of physics to prove that
anti-gravity is impossible is something
very unlikely to be done
even for example well one of the things
I looked at this a couple of years ago
faster than light travel which you know
one sort of assumed based on kind of uh
relativity and so on it's kind of an
axiom nothing goes faster than light by
the way it's worth saying that one of
the sort of stated axioms of Relativity
from 1905 is there is no preferred
reference frame in the universe there's
no there's no sense of absolutely being
at rest or absolutely being in motion
it's all relative so to speak well
that's a fine idea just happens that
there is an absolute reference frame in
our universe which is the center of mass
of the cosmic microwave background the
center of mass of the radiation from The
Big Bang that is a thing where you know
the Earth is moving at one thousandth
the speed of light relative to that
there is a preferred frame of reference
in the universe now one could say well
the fundamental laws of physics don't
depend on that
well that's largely true there are very
few things in in the everyday world
nothing really depends on the cosmic
micro background at least in the current
state of Technology
um and uh well you know it is a
background that is relevant for
satellite Communications but the details
of how fast we're moving relative to it
and so on is not relevant to that but
the idea that the kind of the the
dogmatic statement there is no preferred
reference frame in the universe is just
not true and it's not true also for
these things that lead to the generation
of mass through the spontaneous symmetry
breaking Etc et cetera et cetera there
are it's a more complicated story and it
usually is and so the statement nothing
goes faster than light is again a more
complicated statement in our models of
physics where the structure of space is
this giant Network this giant hypograph
if you look at sort of the average
characteristics of space then yes it
will be true that nothing goes faster
than light but when you look at the
micro details of how that network is put
together well if you found the just the
right piece of network to kind of Trace
down you might very well find that it
goes faster than light it's kind of like
the following thing you've got molecules
of air bouncing around on a run well
every molecule is basically going at the
speed of sound and but if you are kind
of if you release a you know a Ascent
somewhere in the room it'll take a long
time for that scent the molecules and
that scent to diffuse over to the other
side of the room
but in fact every individual molecule a
micron at a time is going at the speed
of sound it's just it hits another
molecule and it randomizes that hitting
of another molecule randomizes the
direction it's going in but if you could
pick if you were a molecular sized
Critter and you could pick I'm going to
ride this molecule now okay I'm seeing
it's going to have a collision with this
one I'm going to jump to this other
molecule I'm going to ride this one now
I'm going to ride that one now you would
actually be able to go at the speed of
sound through the through the room so to
speak by just hopping on the right
molecule at the right time
well the same thing is true for the
structure of space-time if you were able
to sort of hop on the right atom of
space at every moment you would be able
to go faster than the speed of light
small problem you aren't you by the time
you're sort of grinding down to the size
of the atoms of space so to speak the
atoms of space are the indivisible final
points that that space is made out of
and there's not a lot of you you know we
might each be 10 to the 100 atoms of
space and by the time we're sort of
going around at the level of um uh of
atoms of space
um the
uh uh you know there isn't enough we
don't get to stuff a whole 10 to the 100
atoms of space lump of something that is
us the thinking you know human kind of
entity it's it's not us anymore so as a
practical matter for us
we presumably can't go faster than light
at least unless we find some bizarre way
of of uh of of distorting space-time or
we find some space tunnels that I've
sort of talked about a bit
um uh it's it's that the the version of
sort of you know every day going faster
than light is only available to
individual atoms of space so to speak
and even then not really because like
the molecules in the air they're sort of
getting randomized at every moment but
it is interesting
um the uh
um it's um
um uh it's kind of that even these
things were one sort of where physics
has in some level correctly dogmatically
said this works this doesn't work and so
on there are footnotes that arise it
might take 50 years or 100 years but
there are footnotes and sometimes you
get to drive a giant giant truck through
one of those footnotes sometimes you
know I remember uh back in the late
1970s people explaining that you just
couldn't transmit computer data faster
than 300 bits per second that if you had
a copper wire that was part of your
telephone wiring or whatever just
wouldn't work there was a theoretical
reason why 300 bits per second or maybe
a thousand bits per second was the
fastest you'd ever transmit data well
there were loopholes there were
loopholes about well there's this noise
that gets generated in their patterns to
the noise and if you detect the patterns
to the noise and make predictions of
that then you can suddenly send through
more data and so on and pretty soon soon
we're sending through millions of bits
per second through those same kinds of
copper wires and so we found the
loophole so to speak and drove a giant
truck through that loophole and so these
things where people say it's impossible
to do an XYZ I I you know I'm always a
bit skeptical about that because among
other things you have to Define very
precisely what the it that you're trying
to do actually is and undoubtedly it is
the case that the you know kind of skin
depth of transmission of an electrical
signal of this or that kind in a copper
wire is the way people said it was back
then but it turns out if what you want
to do is transmit computer data then you
don't have to do it in that particular
way and so you evade that particular
limitation
all right uh
well I think we should wrap up and I'm
being told I'm late for something else
so thanks for those interesting
questions and um
I look forward to doing this another
time
bye for now